the field of Republican candidates in
the 2024 presidential race is growing
former New Jersey governor that's Chris
Christie former vice president Mike
Pence and North Dakota governor Doug
Byrne burgum are all announcing their
runs Caitlin Huey Burns is in Washington
keeping track of all the candidates who
are getting in Caitlin good morning to
you good morning to you Gail well Chris
Christie will make it official tonight
with a Town Hall in New Hampshire
remember Christie was once a trump Ally
and advisor but now he's trying to set
himself apart from the rest of the field
as one of the toughest Trump critics in
the race
he liked himself more than he liked to
make former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie once used his Street Fighter
brand to defend Donald Trump I am proud
to be here to endorse Donald Trump for
president of the United States now he's
hoping to bring him down I got off the
train when he stood up in the west wing
of the White House
behind the seal the president and told
us the election was stolen Christie is
testing whether there are enough
Republicans willing to get off that
train with him focusing his second run
for the presidency on New Hampshire's
independent voters but he joins an
already crowded field of candidates
which may benefit Trump the answer Iowa
is strong Conservative Republican
leadership former vice president Mike
Pence filed his paperwork for president
and will launch his campaign tomorrow in
Iowa where he hopes to court Evangelical
voters away from his former boss and
North Dakota Republican Governor Doug
burgum will also join The Fray on
Wednesday anger yelling infighting
that's not going to cut it anymore but
one GOP politician is making news for
not jumping into the race New Hampshire
Governor Kristen Nunu says he can be
more effective from the outside I think
more folks within the Republican Party
have to have that kind of voice and
making sure that this is about the
Republican party not just about the
former president
now the next challenge for all of these
candidates is meeting the debate
requirements for that first crucial
debate coming in August and among the
criteria is a pledge to support the
eventual nominee now notably Donald
Trump hasn't said whether he'll sign
such a pledge and actually he's hinted
at skipping that debate altogether Nate
we shall see Caitlin thank you